bonjour fabriquions on le disait on l'a
vu les manifestations qui se poursuivent
à trieste la situation et il est
explosif depuis quelques jours vous vous
êtes penché sur le sujet pouvez vous
nous en dire plus
alors oui en effet en fait le port de la
ville de trieste était occupé depuis
trois jours par les dockers qui était
opposé à l'imposition du pass sanitaires
mais ce blocus a été brisée lundi par
une intervention assez musclée de la
police anti émeute celle ci a notamment
utilisé des canons à eau des gaz
lacrymogènes et a aussi chargé plusieurs
fois les manifestants pour les déloger
après ces scènes d'affrontement
d'ailleurs le gouvernement a estimé
affirmé au parlement que les éléments
violents étaient du côté des
manifestants et non pas de la police le
gouvernement s'est aussi défendu de
vouloir jouer une stratégie de la
tension alors c'est donc la fin de
l'histoire pour ces manifestants
alors en fait l'évacuation de la police
ne les a pas tous découragés ils ont
continué à se rassembler dans le centre
ville de trieste notamment et certains
ayant même passé la nuit
la mobilisation s'est également
poursuivie le lendemain le mardi est un
mouvement citoyen a même été lancé à
cette occasion qui s'appelle cordina
mento queen des fidji alors le nom fait
référence en fait au premier jour du
blocus du port le 15 octobre mais aussi
à l'entrée en vigueur du pass sanitaires
pour se rendent au travail le même jour
son mot d'ordre est récente c'est nous
ne reculerons pas d'un pouce
symptomatique de ce qui se passe en
italie
en fait trieste a la particularité aussi
d'incarner l'épicentre de la résistance
sont ils pas sanitaire en italie le 9
octobre dernier il y avait déjà quinze
mille manifestants qui s'étaient
rassemblés pour cette seule ville de
nombreuses grèves et manifestations ont
aussi eu lieu dans toute la péninsule
vous avez cité rome avant mais il est
aussi gênes ou venise et même des
conseillers régionaux du latium
s'étaient enfermés dans leur bureau en
guise de protestation contre le passé ni
terre imposé pour se rendre sur le
travail
merci beaucoup fabrizzio tribu duo
bugatti pour toutes ces précisions on
peut lire à vos articles sur ce sujet
sur notre site arte france point tva